hey guys i'm ryan right then i'm jerry
who were intense so today i'm gonna be
checking out a special trailer my
girlfriend Veronica six-toes hot ass
latina is the star of a movie that is
premiering at the Los Angeles Film
Festival and it's called pocha manifest
destiny now I remember when she filmed
this movie we weren't dating yet she
went away to Mexico for like six months
and she got super invested in the
character are you Yanni in the middle my
model are you really on that I already
read some early reviews of the film they
love her performance ya know I'm so glad
to hear that too because they're not
have to deal with her crying about it
but know people love her performance I'm
so competitive Gary hasn't seen any
footage of this I saw like a really
early trailer awhile ago but this is the
official trailer so let's check out two
minutes of my girlfriend starring in a
film
it's not a system check with immigration
you were in custody while waiting to
post bail they have placed an
immigration detainer on you you'll never
be allowed back into the United States
I'll get some money together and I'll
come back people do it all the time you
have to go to your father house I need
to know you will be safe abla what is
the problem
shop beautiful it's really very American
I like American girls you could help me
out a little bit do a few runs make
something easy easy
move the category please
well anything your father know where you
were
oh I have to kill you
keep in this struggle people get what
they want
whoa it is Winona community life on the
menu
positive titles are never positive
movies yeah well you would expect like
something positive if you heard manifest
destiny no if you've read a history book
yeah that's fair so what do you think
Jerry then I'll get my thoughts I know I
mean that looks intense man looks heavy
it does look it looks really well shine
I'm dating the storable movie people I'm
dating the star of a movie that's right
the movie star is dating a man who
mainly watches other people's content
and reacts to it and talks about it she
is actually going full emotional
creativity really embodying a role this
looks like it must have been a very
heavy experience because it looks like a
heavy movie no for my understanding from
the few times I actually listen to her
when she was talking no she had to do
like a lot of her own stunts like her
riding that horse
she had no stunt no stunt double and she
was told on that horse seemed like just
go as fast as you can she was terrified
but she did I I once went galloping on a
horse for like ten seconds at most that
was terrified oh yeah absolutely so it's
[ __ ] hot that she was able to do that
you know and that's really her wielding
that flamethrower - I mean do you get
the plot this is trailer could I mean I
get the basic idea you know like she's
she's sent back to back and then in the
struggle to you know sort life out get
back here and whatnot she gets tangled
up in less-than-legal yeah you know look
she's with shady people I mean like it
doesn't give me the super fine details
but I get the point like yeah well
basically yeah it's pretty much
something that she gets caught up in
once she gets sent back to Mexico you
know and like maybe trying to get back
getting involved with the wrong people
exactly family life and all that stuff
exactly
exactly the trailer has communicated to
you what the film is about and then you
know a lot of extra shots of intensity I
don't know if it'll mean much coming
from me because of course I'm gonna say
my girlfriend is doing a great job
knowing that there are early reviews out
saying how fantastic she
and then seeing the trailer it's like I
will forget like honestly this is so
like I saw one scene from this movie and
even when I watched the trailer I start
becoming unaware that that is my
girlfriend interesting you know like I'm
actually pulled into this story and the
character like even when she was getting
her hair pulled
normally I might feel like bastard but
this time around I was like oh that it
looks painful for that actress to go
through that you know because she was
like really getting pulled out of that
trunk that truck yeah it looked heavy
looked painful
yeah it was a rough shoot like a really
really handy shoot you know like I
believe but it's a shot beautifully
though like the director is also the DP
of the film and it is shot like
wonderfully every time I see footage of
it I'm always like really impressed by
it
they're a lot of striking images a lot
of you know playing with light versus
shadow and backlighting oh yeah totally
that's what's cool about it is like it's
a it's a straightforward dramatic tale
but it's got that kind of a unique
imagery about it to tell this kind of
story when it makes you want to see more
because I want to see more of what her
performance is like she's it seems like
hers is the central performance of the
film the trailer communicates the
intensity and now I want to see what the
rest of the film is like you know cuz
they they show mainly those moments for
her and like things are going wrong yeah
so like I want to see the rest of that
performance oh absolutely yeah no it's
it's gonna be it's gonna be kind of an
interesting experience I'm watching it
at the LA Film Festival and I'm I wonder
how I'm gonna respond especially during
that sex scene let's just don't get Paul
Reubens like jerk off to it I mean what
if it's a I mean I hear it's like an
emotional scene it's not like hot and
heavy I don't think this movie's gonna
take a break in the melody like it's hot
[ __ ] sexy yeah I hear it's like a
pretty intense scene and I don't know
how I'm gonna respond in the theatres
well you know you're gonna find out my
likely response is gonna go one of two
ways first way is gonna go this
[ __ ] I bet he's at the premiere
right now where is he I'm gonna kick his
ass
and the other response is this is my
girlfriend look great naked doesn't she
look good naked
really gonna be pleased that you're
advertising this exit into the you know
like to the internal I'll tell you one
thing Jerry she she never watches this
channel and she's probably not even
gonna watch this video might watch this
video I doubt it
she doesn't like my creativity anyway
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out Jerry's play this on this
channel reasons the Jerry and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine been posting on vinyl oddly
they you have we just made one before
this videos guys because if we get
enough followers on our social networks
we can get product placement people
Issac Dale southward just wanted to give
you guys a shout out great Vince chill
as vibes and keep it up shout out if you
want to know if you want I know you like
us big guys like Tyrone haha have a good
one brother and sisters you guys keep it
up you beautiful bastards you thanks
Isaac Dale souther that's very kindly he
say he's a southern southern he says
he's uh he's a big guy like Tyrone let's
just let's see this I mean he's got
pretty blue eyes his hair you know um I
saw a video of dr. Phil interviewing a
man who murdered his mom with a
sledgehammer I'm not sure I don't
remember right now but all I know is he
kind of looks like that kid that's not a
cool thing to truck I know what's to
think about it like this
what a compliment yeah right said to you
this guy Isaac looks like a man who
murdered his mother haha and I pointed
at his photo would you not go yeah that
looks like the kind of guy who would
murder his mom not just off a photo like
well you're not only not as judgmental
as I have this photo maybe you should
show me maybe if you have a creepier
photo shut up